tonight he makes his first start since
the no-hitter at home joe was the type
to uh
kind of just erase all that and uh
concentrate on the task at hand
that would be start number four and the
first start as donnie mentioned since no
hit her at home opponents only hitting
109 off of joe musgrove jackie bradley
jr the longtime red sox will stand in to
lead off swing and a miss and jackie
bradley jr
strikes out good start for joe musgrove
one down does that slider look familiar
it should because that was the go-to
pitch against the rangers and the no
hitter a couple of quick answer must
grow over the top of the first inning
base is empty and here you go first
right-handed hitter of the night trying
to check his swing on a slider they
appeal he went and a one two three top
of the first inning for musgrove with a
couple of strikeouts
and brandon woodruff making start number
four i mean he's got excellent numbers a
212 run run average opponent batting
average at 169.
three walks 19 strikeouts for brandon so
corona worth it first pro far and third
nobody out fernando tatis junior
cronenworth does run from first in a
slowly hit ground ball to shortstop
that'll get a run home marias has it off
balance throw to first in time and a one
to nothing padre lead rbi ground out
fernando tati's junior chronoworth at
second base with one away well because
they've started crowned worth no double
play possibility they're
gonna run scores maria said shortstop
former padre and a fan favorite despite
his limited action in the big leagues
and he swings at the first pitch and
launches one to deep right myers going
back looking up gonna go welcome back to
san diego
luis suarez
a solo blast and we are tied at one his
second of the year oh luis arias
flexing on joe musgrove
jumped on the first pitch opposite field
home run
his second of the year and we are tied
at one and the first hit musgrove has
allowed this year to a right-handed
batter
so two down now for will myers
six in a row now retired by woodruff and
now
he was right around the strike zone
third walk issued by woodruff he's upset
as is his manager cory blazer squeezed
him a couple of times tonight
and it's a ground ball one hops shaw at
third and he throws a cross in time
for the final out
sounded like it might have broken the
bat of tommy pham
and shaw got it on a short hop
and made the play and the brewers out of
the inning one out in the fifth and it
brings up billy mckinney who also struck
out in the second inning fly ball right
field well struck back at the track it's
gone
billy mckinney his first as a brewer
gives the crew a 2-1 lead over the
padres
a cutter on the inner part of the plate
and billy mckinney went down and got it
two hits two solo home runs and the
brewers have a 2-1 lead in san diego
don't go down and in and the reaction
from victor carratini told you
everything he wanted to know he reached
out to try and catch that one
and as soon as contact was made he put
his helmet
down and his chin into his chest
brandon woodruff now stake to a lead
and he will take over here at the bottom
of the fifth four innings he's given up
just the one run that came
in the first inning a 28 pitch first
inning and he's been streamlined since
delivery to carratini struck him out
looking with a fastball at the knees
strikeout number three for brandon
woodruff and it brings up joe muscaro
the opposing pitcher pitches swung on
and missed for the fastball
and now jericks and profar hits
struck him out looking
woodruff strikes out the side in the
fifth
if he is done
he went out with a flash no doubt about
that would you vote for one with a
strikeout joe has 10 k's
in five innings to match his padre high
swung on and missed and musgrove has
tied his career high 11 strikeouts here
tonight when you throw two of the first
three for strikes you're giving yourself
a chance to win jackie bradley swings at
the first pitch lines it right back to
joe who made the catch
osgrove stuck the glove out right around
his belt buckle
took about a half a step towards first
base made the play and all bradley can
do is take off his batting helmet look
out at joe and then walk back to the
dugout two away brandon woodruff working
on a gem in san diego brewers up two to
one
five innings one run one hit three walks
and six strikeouts for woodruff here's
tatis he has driven in the only run of
the game for the padres that was with a
ground out back in the first inning he's
over two struck him out change up on the
inside corner strikeout number seven for
brandon woodruff two gone in the sixth
manny machado sends one in the air to
center not deep jackie bradley junior's
there makes the catch
and the inning is over six strong from
brandon woodruff
here's mckinney who homered in his last
at bat that put the brewers in front two
to one swung on in miss strike three
that is number 12 for joe musgrove a new
career high got the left-hand hitter to
chase the change up down and away with
two outs man on first james peterson the
left-handed batter coming up swinging
him in peterson all tied up by a great
slider down and in that is it for joe
musgrove
she goes seven strikes out 13. throws 96
pitches hopes his club can come from
behind here tying run at first base for
san diego with two outs here in the
seventh martini looking for a little two
out magic there goes the runner here's
the pitch swinging to miss on a change
at the throw to second is in time
they got him robertson applied the tag
as narvaez gets another
brewer is out of the inning
through pomeranz is on for the sixth
time the padres he's yet to allow a run
swinging a fly ball hit to center way
back
fam it's gone tyrone taylor
pinch hit blast
3-1 brewers
third solo home run of the game for
milwaukee
pomeranz fell behind 2-0 taylor was
sitting dead red and he hit it right off
the batter's eye and straight away
center that'll put a jolt into that
brewers dugout taylor's first of the
season second hit of the season for
tyrone taylor no doubt about that one so
that's the first out of the inning now
pro far who hits from the right side of
the plate
tying around at the plate profile ground
ball second base double play ball
robertson steps on the back throws the
first in time
suiter just as quickly as he started the
inning he gets right out of it padres
will bring the tying run to the plate
world-class matchup right here manny
machado against josh hayder and he
struck him out
got him to chase one and now it's up to
eric hosmer slider bounce to the right
side a fair ball here has got it steps
on the bag and the ball game is over
brewers three padres one